ich nehme dieses video auf am ersten
april 2020 in deutschland während 73
1217 krone fälle gezählt
802 toten kitas schulen geschäfte sind
geschlossen soziale kontakte auf ein
minimum beschränkt viele sind gerade
arbeitslos oder auftrags los während
sich andere kaputt arbeiten um dieses
land am laufen zu halten bis nach ostern
sind diese maßnahmen noch angedacht
danach will man weiterschauen so heißt
es momentan
ich meine wie lange kann man so einen
ausnahmezustand schon durchhalten
ich fürchte wir brauchen noch etwas
ausdauer noch ziemlich viel ausdauer
solange wir keinen impfstoff haben ist
die pandemie erst vorbei wenn sich 60
bis 70 prozent der bevölkerung infiziert
haben beziehungsweise wenn sich 60 bis
70 prozent infiziert haben wieder erholt
haben dann erstmal immun sind dann haben
wir nämlich herdenimmunität das heißt es
sind genügend menschen immun damit der
ausbruch zum erliegen kommt 60 bis 70
prozent sind in deutschland 48 bis 56
millionen menschen recht indem man
stellen wir haben jetzt in deutschland
ungefähr 73.000 fälle nehmen wir mal an
die dunkelziffer sei zehnmal so hoch
also auf jeden infizierten kommen noch
mal neun nicht detektiert
dann hätten wir 730.000 fälle 730.000
von 48 bis 56 millionen
also wir haben wahrscheinlich gerade ein
bisschen mehr als ein prozent herren
immunität die korona krise geht also
gerade erst richtig los wie lange müssen
wir also noch durchhalten als antwort
hört man momentan vor allem das ist noch
zu früh zu sagen jetzt mal abwarten wie
effektiv unsere maßnahmen sein werden
schauen wir mal dann sehen wir ja über
ein paar dinge sollten wir jetzt schon
ausführlich sprechen und auch zahlen
anschauen die man vielleicht nicht sehen
möchte deswegen holt euch ein tee macht
es euch gemütlich denn soviel vorweg wir
brauchen geduld
eins vorweg es ist natürlich richtig
dass wir gerade auf die daten über die
wirksamkeit unserer aktuellen maßnahmen
warte sie haben wir erst in zwei drei
wochen darüber will ich jedoch nicht
spekulieren
ich meine es ist ja auch richtig und
wichtig im nebel auf sicht zu fahren
aber wir wollen doch trotzdem ungefähr
wissen wie lang die straße sein wird
oder und die sache ist die über die
länge der straße wissen wir jetzt schon
ziemlich gut bescheid
und bei all der berichterstattung über
die korona krise ist genau das ein punkt
über den meiner meinung nach zu wenig
diskutiert
um das alles zu verstehen kurz vorweg
ein paar basics zu allgemeinen epidemie
maßnahmen die phasen der epidemie
bekämpfung phase 1 content unter
containment verstehen epidemiologen
eindämmung also idealer weise versucht
man die krankheit im keim zu ersticken
zu solchen ein dämmungsmaßnahmen gehören
kranke isolieren kontakte nachverfolgen
isolieren auf das virus testen also
überblick behalten und die verbreitung
verhindern
es kann aber schnell mal sowas passieren
wie zum beispiel in heinsberg also ein
infiziertes paar feiert mit 300 weiteren
karneval und dann kommt man schon kaum
mehr hinterher
irgendwann übersteigt die nachverfolgung
und der kontakte den verwaltungsapparat
endphase zwei medikation am besten zu
übersetzen mit schadensbegrenzung wenn
wir nicht mehr nachvollziehen können wir
jetzt alles infiziert es klappt jetzt
diese gezielte isolierung nicht mehr
deswegen müssen wir alle mitmachen also
abstand halten
home office veranstaltung absagen usw er
kennt es in dieser phase hat man den
versuch eine einblendung erstmal
aufgegeben aber man will jetzt
wenigstens die ausbreitung verlangsame
warum das so wichtig ist dürfte
inzwischen bei jedem angekommen seien
über flächen gekauft wurde in letzter
zeit so viel gesprochen dass das
grundprinzip von mitigation den meisten
klar sein sollte aber dieses rein
qualitative verständnis kann trügerisch
werden also noch mal kurz wiederholen
und je langsamer die epidemie verläuft
desto weniger menschen sind gleichzeitig
infiziert und es so weniger menschen
brauchen gleichzeitig medizinische
behandlung
so verhindern wir dass unser
gesundheitssystem zusammenbricht was wir
leider gerade in italien spanien oder
new york mit schrecken beobachten wenn
die intensivstation nicht mehr genug
betten für alle patienten haben dann
müssen schreckliche entscheidungen über
leben und tod getroffen werden das darf
nicht passieren das problem ist jetzt
dass gerade bei vielen folgende eindruck
entsteht der doktor ist heftig aber wir
gehen jetzt gerade auch alles und
hoffentlich kriegen wir damit die kurve
so flach dass wir vielleicht nach ostern
vielleicht ein bisschen später das ganze
einigermaßen glimpflich hinter uns
gebracht haben diese vorstellung ist
leider realitätsferne fantasie warum das
so ist verstehen wir wenn wir uns
konkrete zahlen anschauen fangen wir an
mit einer zentralen größe die re
produktionszahl die basis reproduktions
zahl eher 0 gibt an wie viele menschen
eine infizierte person im durchschnitt
ansteckt wenn niemand immun ist und wenn
keine maßnahmen getroffen werden für das
saas kroner virus 2 wird er 0 derzeit
auf zwei bis drei geschätzt
das heißt jeder infizierte steckt im
schnitt zwei bis drei weitere an wenn
die reproduktions zahl auf unter 1 feld
das heißt jeder infizierte steckt im
schnitt weniger als eine weitere person
an
dann kommt der ausbruch zu berlin alle
maßnahmen die wir jetzt so die letzten
woche mitbekommen haben vom aufruf zum
händewaschen über kontakt verfolgung bis
zum lockdown dienen dazu die
reproduktions zahl zu senken
wir sprechen dann von der effektiven re
produktionszahl grafisch gesprochen die
kleiner die reproduktions zahl desto
flacher die kurve wie flach ist nun
flach genug diese frage wird beantwortet
in der stellungnahme der deutschen
gesellschaft für epidemiologie zur
ausbreitung des neuen corona virus hier
findet man modellierungen für
verschiedene szenarien diese
modellierungen sind wohlgemerkt keine
voraussagen
jede epidemie ist ein einzelfall
deswegen arbeiten ja gerade auch
forscher mit hochdruck daran dieses neue
virus besser zu verstehen aber
modellierungen können verschiedene
denkbare szenarien durchrechnen in deren
rahmen sich der zukünftige verlauf
bewegen könnte und anhand dieser
szenarien
können wir ableiten welche maßnahmen den
verlauf in welcher form beeinflussen
können sowie würden nun die effektivere
produktionszahl den verlauf beeinflussen
oder konkreter gesagt wie stark müssen
wir die re produktionszahl senken damit
die kurve hinreichend flach wird also so
flach dass unser gesundheitssystem ist
handeln kann
dazu brauchen wir jetzt mal eine
vorstellung davon wie groß die
kapazitäten unseres gesundheitssystems
in deutschland sind dazu gehört
natürlich vieles also beatmungsgeräte
schutzkleidung für das personal
natürlich auch das personal an sich aber
nehmen wir mal ein limitieren sind
faktor mit dem wir das ganze durch
rechnen können nämlich die anzahl der
betten auf den intensivstationen auf die
die schweren verläufe angewiesen sind in
deutschland gibt es derzeit rund 30.000
intensivmedizinische betten die sind
aber nicht alle frei
bei allen laufenden bemühungen die
kapazitäten aufzustocken sind natürlich
viele dieser betten besetzt von nicht
kroner patienten aber nehmen wir für
unsere betrachtung jetzt einfach mal an
wie hetzen 30.000 freie betten okay wie
viele menschen werden jetzt wegen covi
19 ein bett auf einer intensivstation
brauchen und wie lange muss man sie dort
behandeln die deutsche gesellschaft für
epidemiologie schätzt dass zwei bis
sechs prozent der korona infizierten ein
intensiv bett brauchen die liegedauer
ist verhältnismäßig lagen nämlich 10 bis
20 tage also je nach patient wir wurden
jetzt neun verschiedene szenarien
modelliert mit zwei vier oder sechs
prozent intensiv pflichtigen patienten
und mit 10 15 oder 20 tagen liegedauer
schauen wir uns zuerst das quest case
szenario in dem nur zwei prozent der
erkrankten eine intensiv bahn und
brauchen und zwar alle nur für zehn tage
in diesem szenario würde man bei einer
re produktionszahl von 1,5 also das ist
die grüne kurve die kapazitäten über
einen langen zeitraum komplett springen
erst bei einer re produktionszahl von
1,25 nähern wir uns zwar der 30.000
betten kräfte würden sie zu peak zeile
aber immer noch springen
wenn sie jetzt nicht zwei sondern vier
prozent sind dann sind sie direkt
doppelt so viele patienten die in welt
brauchen bei den meisten diese szenarien
der muss die produktionszahl auf 1,1
oder sehr nah an 1,1 heruntergedrückt
werden um eine überbelastung der
intensivstation zu vermeiden und im
worst case szenario haben wir selbst bei
einer re produktionszahl von 1,1 zu
kriegszeiten zehntausende menschen
täglich die nicht behandelt werden
können zusammengefasst um unser
gesundheitssystem nicht zu überlasten
brauchen wir maßnahmen welche die
effektivere produktionszahl auf einen
bereich zwischen 1,25 und 1,1 senken ihr
könnt euch vorstellen dass das du mit
ordentlicher kontakt reduktion möglich
ist aber jetzt schaut man auf die
zeitachse bei diesen strengen maßnahmen
wäre die epidemie erst nach einem jahr
vorbei beziehungsweise in den meisten
fällen noch länger so die flachste kurve
die dunkelblaue die ist hier
abgeschnitten also wir gehen hier
richtung zwei jahre unterm strich heißt
das um den zusammenbruch unseres
gesundheitssystems zu vermeiden müssen
wir strenge maßnahmen für ein bis zwei
jahre lang aufrechterhalten und das geht
nicht wir sehen ja jetzt schon welche
immensen schäden für die volkswirtschaft
zu erwarten sind da hängen existenzen
und damit auch wieder menschenleben dran
und auch welche allgemeinen
gesellschaftlichen auch psychologischen
folgen das hätte langfristig das können
wir derzeit noch gar nicht fassen ich
weiß dass bei diesen modellierungen
nicht nur an namen sondern auch
vereinfachungen gemacht wurde und ich
weiß auch dass es noch parameter gibt es
über chur wird 19 die wir jetzt noch
nicht kennen die aber einen wesentlichen
einfluss haben wie zum beispiel was
jetzt eigentlich mit den sehr schwach
oder sogar asymptomatischen vergriffen
ist
aber allein diese größenordnung wenn die
größenordnung nicht völlig daneben ist
dann ist flehten curve bis zur herren
die immunität nicht durchhaltbar -
dieser stellungnahme nicht brandneu also
sie wurde am tag von merkels ansprache
veröffentlicht und paar tage später
aktualisiert aber wenn ich jetzt heute
in die medienberichte schaue dann wird
immer noch der eindruck vermittelt als
sei fettende curve nach wie vor der
masterplan und wie kann das sein wenn
das offenbar so nicht aufgehen wird ja
aber auch mit professor raphael
mikolajczyk geredet der diese
stellungnahme mitverfasst hat um mich zu
versichern dass wir nicht etwas
grundlegendes missverstanden haben
vielen dank an dieser stelle für das
aufschlussreiche hintergrundgespräch
aber ja die ergebnisse sind nicht anders
zu interpretieren die antwort auf die
frage wie stark müssen wir die
reproduktion style senken damit die
kurve hinreichend flach wird lautet die
re produktionszahl muss auf unter 1
gesenkt werden
den abflachen alleine würde zu lange
dauern wir müssen die kurve stoppen kurz
und schmerzhaft zurück zum start die
fallzahl muss so klein werden dass
unsere gesundheitsämter wieder dazu in
der lage sind alles helle zu überschauen
zu verfolgen dann können wir nämlich
wieder effektiv kranke isolieren
kontakte verfolgen kontakt hätten
brechen die krankheit eindämmen
das bedeutet wenn die infektionszahlen
nicht mehr nur langsamer steigen sondern
wirklich abnehmen dann kommen wir
irgendwann wieder zu einem punkt wo wir
mit unseren maßnahmen die dabei phase 1
containment sind und dann ja dann würde
für viele menschen wieder so etwas wie
normalität zurückkehren denn dann wären
die strengen maßnahmen wieder nur
gezielt auf die erkrankten und ihre
kontaktperson konzentriert nur ist der
weg zurück zur phase 1 natürlich nur mit
strengen maßnahmen für alle machbar
nochmal ein infizierter muss weniger als
einen weiteren anstecken damit das
aufgeht also wie schnell hat man zwei
personen angesteckt vor allem wenn man
vielleicht ich darauf achte wahl eher
milde symptome hat oder wenn irgendwo
jemand zehn weitere menschen ansteckt
bei irgendeiner veranstaltung dann
dürfen neuen andere niemanden mehr
anstecken reichen denn nun unsere
aktuellen maßnahmen aus um die re
produktionszahl so stark zu senken eben
auf diese einschätzung warten wir ja
gerade aber soviel kann man schon mal
sagen dass dieser locker und beschlossen
wurde ist definitiv angemessen und
richtig also wenn wir wirklich zur phase
eins zurück wollen dann ist das was wir
gerade machen auf keinen fall
übertrieben oder unnötig strengen denn
wir können jetzt schon sagen dass wir
noch ziemlich weit entfernt sind von
einer fallzahl die niedrig genug ist
denken wir das mal durch im netz gibt es
einige online simulationen von epidemien
mit denen man herumspielen kann jetzt
mal nur zur veranschaulichung der ist
ganz gut kann ist hier die parameter so
was wie ansteckung hospitalisierung des
rad und so weiter so einstellt wie die
deutsche gesellschaft für epidemiologie
in ihrem generation gemacht hat und dann
schauen wie lange es dauern wird bis wir
wieder zu kontern mit übergehen können
jetzt muss ich ihnen annahme treffen
nämlich wie tief die fallzahl sinken
muss also ab welcher fallzahl
containment wieder möglich wäre die
wirkliche zahl hängt zum beispiel ganz
stark ab von unseren test kapazitäten
davon wie viel ressourcen und personal
noch in die behörden stecken können wie
gut die infrastruktur ist und so weiter
aber orientieren wir uns mal an den tag
an denen jens spahn sagte dass man
veranstaltungen mit mehr als 1000
menschen ab sein sollte können
spätestens dann gab es offenbar ein
problem mit der nachverfolgen
an diesem tag gab es in deutschland
ungefähr 1000 fälle zunehmen jetzt
einfach mal 1000 wäre jetzt die fallzahl
die noch händelbar wäre ohne dass wir
jetzt irgendwelche drastischen social
systems inc maßnahmen für alle bräuchten
jetzt haben wir heute circa 70.000 fans
können wir hier einstellen dass wir ab
dem tag wo die epidemie 70.000 fälle hat
die reproduktions sal
2 auf 0,5 runterdrücken revolution zwar
0,5 das ist volle kanone also das ist wo
hans glocker und so muss man sich das
vorstellen und unter diesen annahmen
würde es 56 tage dauern bis wir wieder
weniger als 1.000 vertreten also fast
zwei monate das sollte jetzt natürlich
keine prognose sein sondern nur ein
beispiel szenario um ein gefühl dafür zu
kriegen wie lange das noch dauern könnte
und nur damit dass niemand falsch
versteht wenn wir es schaffen mit harten
maßnahmen zurück zur phase eins zu
kommen ist damit ja die epidemie noch
nicht vorbei wir kommen damit lediglich
in einen zustand in dem sowohl unser
gesundheitssystem als auch unsere
wirtschaft funktionieren können also in
einen zustand in dem wir so lange
ausharren können bis die epidemie vorbei
ist kleiner einschub ist gibt noch ein
paar unbekannte eigenschaften des virus
die uns vielleicht schneller ans ziel
bringen könnten zum beispiel eine
saisonalität das heißt dass das virus im
sommer weniger ansteckend sein könnte
oder dass doch ein teil der bevölkerung
eine gewisse immunität gegen dieses
virus haben könnte dazu gibt es
modellierungen vom robert koch institut
die haben wir euch mit ner kurzen
einordnung in die video beschreibung
gepackt habe an der strategie an sich
würde das auch nichts ändern
es wäre auf jeden fall falsch aus einer
unbestätigten hoffnung heraus maßnahmen
zu lockern denn so oder so gilt je
schneller wir in phase eins zurück sind
desto besser
das klingt jetzt nach ganz schön harter
arbeit nur um dahin wieder zurück zu
kommen wo wir schon vor einem monat
waren aber ganz wichtig wir gehen nicht
einfach nur ein schritt zurück beim
zweiten mal wird alles besser
die containment phase am anfang einer
epidemie steht unter folgendem dilemma
je früher man maßnahme greift desto
effektiver ist es aber da eine epidemie
anfangs natürlich nicht so schlimm ist
wird die bedrohung oft zu spät erkannt
auch hierzulande wurde corona anfangs
von vielen menschen nicht ernst genommen
und politische entscheidungsträger sind
ja nur das eine
auch ohne akzeptanz in der bevölkerung
kann man strenge maßnahmen wie jetzt zum
beispiel karneval absagen in einer
demokratie kaum durchsetzen aber wenn
wir jetzt wieder zurück ins containment
kommen dann wissen wir wieder hase läuft
wir sind inzwischen auch alle profis in
hände waschen und in ellenbogen husten
und abstand halten und basteln sogar
gerade an zusätzlichen maßnahmen wie
selbst genähte gesichtsmasken auch unser
gesundheitssystem und die forschung sind
jetzt natürlich deutlich weiter und
gerade werden test kapazitäten
hochgefahren
die behörden werden mit mehr manpower
ausgestattet und so weiter also nicht
falsch verstehen ich finde deutschland
hat durchaus vernünftig auf die krise
reagiert aber wenn wir jetzt phase eins
noch mal wiederholen würden dann würden
wir an allen möglichen ecken und enden
die sache deutlich besser machen einfach
nur weil wir jetzt vieles wissen was wir
vorher nicht wussten nur sollten uns
klar machen wir arbeiten auf eine
lockerung der maßnahmen und einen
rückgewinn von normalität hin
aber ganz ohne verzicht werden wir lange
zeit nicht auskommen dazu gehört
vermeidbare menschenansammlungen also
konzerte gefüllte fußballstadien dicht
gepackte rheinstrecke konferenzen dieses
jahr vergesst es wäre auch in der con
themen phase zu riskant mit nur einem
ausbruch könnten wir uns unsere ganzen
bemühungen wieder kaputt macht ja selbst
après ski in der kommenden wintersaison
dafür sehe ich schwarz denn eine
timeline habe ich noch für euch wann
endet diese epidemie im prinzip habe ich
das am anfang schon gesagt
natürlicherweise ist die epidemie erst
dann vorbei wenn herdenimmunität
erreicht ist aber das ist nur theorie in
der praxis können wir natürliche herrn
immunität quasi vergessen es gibt kein
szenario bei dem wir eine herrenteam
unität von 60 bis 70 prozent erreichen
könnten ohne dass dabei unvorstellbare
schäden entstehen also entweder würden
wir die kapazitäten unseres
gesundheitssystems sprengen dabei würden
erschreckend viele menschen sterben oder
wir würden diese herren immunität
unterhalb der kapazität unseres
gesundheitssystems verfolgen
aber das würde so lange dauern dass es
wirtschaftlich und gesellschaftlich
nicht er tragbar wäre daraus kann ich
nur eins schließen nämlich diese
epidemie wird erst mit einem impfstoff
enden theoretisch auch mit dem
medikament das aber auch die
intensivbehandlung weitgehend ersetzen
müsste fast leider unwahrscheinlich ist
das heißt bis zum impfstoff müssen wir
durchhalten
die entwicklung braucht zeit also
sportliche schätzungen sprechen hier von
frühjahr 2021 und damit wir das so lange
mit möglichst wenig schäden durch halten
müssen wir jetzt mit harten maßnahmen
möglichst schnell zurück zum kontern mit
modus in dem wir dann bei relativer
normalität ausharren können
ich weiß dass vieles in diesem video
euch wahrscheinlich entmutigt hat ich
sehe das so ich habe lieber einen
konkreten ausweg vor augen auch wenn er
schwer ist als immer nur mit wir müssen
mal schauen im ungewissen gehalten zu
werden wenn wir das ziel kennen können
wir natürlich auch besser zielen also
wir können jetzt schon weitere
hilfsmaßnahmen in die wege leiten oder
home office strukturen wo denn möglich
weiter ausbauen und uns jetzt schon mal
gedanken machen wie wir irgendwie länger
durchhalten es ist marathon
aber ich kann auch nicht verstehen wie
menschen 42 kilometer laufen können und
trotzdem schaffen sie es deswegen
freunde der sonne lasst euch nicht
unterkriegen und wenn ihr irgendwelche
motivierenden gedanken oder ideen zur
ausdauer habt schreibt sie gerne in die
kommentare
ich hoffe ihr seid gesund und ihr
schlagt euch irgendwie tapfer durch
diese unwirkliche zeit
mir geht es gut das baby ist da es ist
ein sehr sehr süßes freundchen der sonne
und wir sind zum glück alle gesund aber
mein herz geht raus an alle die von prof
19 getroffen sind entweder selbst oder
im freundes- oder familienkreis an alle
die sich gerade den hintern aufreißen um
diesen laden am laufen zu halten die
sich um unsere gesundheit kümmern und um
unsere grundversorgung
und auch an alle die jetzt gerade nicht
arbeiten können oder nicht bezahlt
werden es ist wirklich eine verdammt
heftige zeit zum glück kann ich
wenigstens my life von zu hause aus
produzieren
auch wenn wir im team gerade etwas
langsamer vorankommen weil sowohl haas
als auch melanie kita kind zu hause
haben
deswegen hat es melanie auch nicht
geschafft diese freude grafiken zu
machen aber vielleicht habt ihr es
gemerkt hat ein neues kanal design
erstellt das ich sehr sehr cool finde
wir hoffen es gefällt euch natürlich ist
das ganze social dissing die abschottung
auch psychologisch ist nicht ohne und
wenn es euch auch so geht kann ich euch
das video von meiner lieben kollegin pia
empfehlen
hier hat jetzt einen ganz neuen
funkkanal aufgemacht psychologie schaut
er gerne mal vorbei das paar grüße ak
kekse von mir da und jetzt endlich auch
hiermit ein verspätetes aber umso fettes
dankeschön für euren tollen support also
erstmal danke für die vielen super
lieben kommentare unter dem letzten
video
ich habe mich sehr bewegt also es die
haben es einerseits leicht aber auch
wieder schwer gemacht in die pause zu
gehen und auch danke für alle die mir
während der pause aus den letzten
monaten geschrieben haben ich habe das
mit einem halben auge mitbekommen wenn
ich habe nicht nur youtube pause gemacht
sondern tatsächlich auch social media
und e mail pause aber ich freue mich
jetzt wieder zurück zu sein
auch auf instagram und twitter teilt
dieses video mit jedem dienst
interessieren könnte erzählt euren
freunden dass meile beck ist es gibt ab
jetzt jeden zweiten donnerstag ein neues
video deswegen wir sehen uns in zwei
wochen und bis dahin
es hat noch nie so sehr gepasst wie
jetzt bleibt sicher